have to go read I spear to pass welcome
to another awesome episode of prop we're
coming that we're coming at you're not
doing it right
what are you talking about this is
exactly how you play prop fun I become
one with the world and I look totally
legit
molding pipe before but you're talking
about that sounds so wrong ah where are
you damn it I'm right in front of you so
is there a command up you play into G so
what is this beta mama's doing right
here that's say that hey hey I know but
anyway oh my god I can't believe you
could be like a little can of soup
whatever that is not a can of soup I
swear to God
what you can you can switch Memphis oh
how are you surviving all this fire
where did you go
I'm here huh what's up what's going on I
don't know much just chilling yeah yeah
just tell him I seem to recall all these
bills being here hmm that's weird
that's the best funniest you're right at
surrender Hansen captain hey hey what no
no so shitty how do you keep
disappearing
hey are you and your brightness up okay
right out to a gun just done bounced
around him
oh oh oh
and we don't have that much time [ __ ]
this is a terrible and now I'm stuck too
great
are you may go eunsuk me okay just poker
face right now cuz they're gonna come
okay
no no how we got plenty of time I'm
stuck as well now [ __ ] right I can get
you out
oh [ __ ] don't move stop this one oh let
him up there there's still awesome it
would be so awesome if I could stay oh
my god did I get you
maybe you did actually free me out so I
can oh yeah
whatever he's down here he's okay she's
in here oh hello little buddy
what worried by this bottle buddy no way
ready good why are you running
oh yeah no friends it did not work the
last time but you better damn work this
time are there anything we can enter you
I don't think so no just way it's right
here
just take your time guys Oh excellent
wait oh here we go
[ __ ] just leave into the wall okay all
right
really eagle man oh oh yeah we did okay
cool
SMG shotgunners yeah SMD look the
truckin scientist I think your name them
um uh yeah I think so and say wait a
minute what's going on yeah hey what the
hell
we're just shoots there were none people
for never odd sir stuff in this corner
Oh Kyle shut anything wait we reread the
book it's moving
no it's not oh yeah I see I see I see it
first but wait on table which well I
think as I can see you here holding this
item you're not supposed to hold item
I'm up you didn't just eat you let him
go it's kind of a dead giveaway just Oh
oh my god you ready for that was home
hey buddy
show yourself right here meet me in the
gray house guys dad I think you can be
more romantic Chris Ryan behind you can
you you disrespected me you [ __ ] damn
ah that's amazing
Hey oh what a melon what the [ __ ] oh
stop it dangerous I wanna eat you come
here
all right listen woman willing go hey
let's go be edgy oh god oh god it's so
funny
nobody's opening this of watermelon side
watermelon oh no everything's gone black
for me alright yeah we're waiting I know
I've no idea we go up here we start on
opposite sides
oh it's our my never degrades foot
I'm there guys but take one watch
another couch I swear I'm gonna hit
everything
oh it's brighter and a half on the
wrestler whoa damn like a karate chop
yeah I D uh we're the same item Lee
Rapids was [ __ ] oh oh you scared me I
just sorta studied the door and I was
like I don't know how to take this oh
[ __ ]
oh right there right there oh [ __ ] you
see haven't see him
mmm you got one where is he
the suspicious newspaper sound there a
newspaper eat suspicious but she's a guy
believe it seriously
I'll make a run for it like near the end
all times okay can you see me now I'm
just moving on it's pot cases are you
are you one of these maybe I had jeez
don't you die don't you die don't you
that wait man oh my god
what the heck I see one of these giant
bookcases move it's that thing it was
the way for the whole time seriously the
favor though it's all going snow ah did
you not kill it that I did I all righty
then wait are you gasps I don't
appreciate Hey what you guys doing
are you sure the cup was head by the way
I am it was like that no I moved that
was over huh I heard it does a door
closed automatically hello
if he out of place nope just now no they
cause an open no no it opened
wait a second heart stop mind [ __ ] us
okay why that door open now I'm gonna
die say oh no am i have already still
open myself is that it [ __ ] a door I
swear to God hey who's who's in here me
you'll know I'm here too I'm like
grossly out of place
I see somebody shooting you see somebody
shooting ha yeah you just turned around
really quick
get away yeah I was I was so
horrendously stuck don't you stay there
like that
I can't even escape plan though and I
don't really have that close that it you
are both like really far away that big
one else
melons is here someone oh yeah this way
what about now okay so I'm gonna have a
lesson for today um what's her I'm from
I drop my journal I'm ready to learn sir
okay conference only you're late for
class
come on there are flares yeah you're
late for class
I see yesterday it's gonna fail you if
you don't turn up on time come on let's
have a seat what the hell what but did
you go on a reelin gave a [ __ ]
watermelon in you hello
you Malin Aidan's melon okay to see
alright brothers hope you enjoyed yet
another episode
maybe like if you did I really
appreciate it bro hit subscribe to
become a bro today and I will see you in
the next video sales and breath love you
oh he hugs me back stay down
[ __ ]
hey don't be [ __ ] each other in front
of me that's gross
this was read